JOHN PEMBERTON WAS TRYING
TO MAKE PATENT MEDICINES.
BASICALLY,
THEY WERE FAKE MEDICINES,
AND MOST OF THEM WERE JUST,
LIKE, HERBAL WHOSIWHATS.
WHO EVEN CARES?
WE WAS JUST TRYING TO MAKE
ANYTHING THAT WOULD SELL.
WE WAS LIKE,
I WANT TO MAKE A FAKE MEDICINE
THAT MADE WOMEN THINK
THAT THEY'LL NEVER BE NERVOUS
OR HAVE FARTS...
AND MAKE MEN THINK
THAT THEY CAN BE SMARTER.
SO HE DECIDED TO USE
A NEW INGREDIENT, COCA.
COCA IS FROM A PLANT.
THE SOUTH AMERICANS
WOULD CHEW IT,
AND BE LIKE,
WE HAD SO MUCH ENERGY,
AND WE WEREN'T EVEN HUNGRY,
AND WE HIKED THE WHOLE ANDES.
[laughs]
BUT REALLY,
THEY WERE
JUST ON COCAINE.
JOHN PEMBERTON WAS LIKE,
OH, I SHOULD PUT THIS
INTO MY NEW POTION
THAT I'M MAKING.
AND BASICALLY, HE COPIED
SOMEONE ELSE'S RECIPE,
CALLED, LIKE,
"VIN MARIANI."
HE WAS LIKE,
WELL, I HAVE WINE.
I PUT COCA IN THERE,
A LITTLE OF THIS KOLA IN.
THE KOLA NUT RELEASED
A LITTLE BIT OF CAFFEINE.
AND HE--HE BASICALLY
WAS LIKE,
WHAT I GIVE YOU
IS WINE WITH COCAINE--
[laughs]
CAFFEINE.
THEN, PEOPLE IN ATLANTA
WERE LIKE,
NO, NOBODY CAN SELL ALCOHOL
BECAUSE OF TEMPERANCE.